6 45 into friday morning what's cool at
school a youngster-driven project that
helps our military families sleep better
at night well when an elementary school
in north las vegas is just a hop skip
and a jump away from the air force base
you can bet there are plenty of students
with parents or even siblings serving
our nation
and thanks to an industrious teacher at
watson elementary some 50 of those kids
were all in on operation pillowcase
joanie
operation pillowcase is really a morale
building um opportunity where our
students were able to decorate a
pillowcase with either their parent or
their siblings photo on it thanks to a
wonderful contributions from not only
local nevadans but outside of the state
we were able to get our donors choose
project funded which supplied the
pillowcases the iron-on transfers the
stencils the fabric markers so it's a
great time for our kids to come together
realize that there's other kids at the
school that are just like them and of
course we ended our pillowcase party
with some pizza and some cookies
that's how you want to end that way to
go miss cervanic and the watson
wranglers now as if operation pillowcase
wasn't enough they're now gearing up for
valentine's for veterans collecting
valentine's care package snacks to send
to servicemen and women overseas if you
want to help with that we've got the
link in the online version of this story
on eightnewsnow.com if you know
something that's cool at school let us
know coolant school is under the
community tab on eightnewsnow.com or you
can send us an email cool at school
eightnewsnow.com